nove persone su dieci a mano il
cioccolato la decima mente
a quanti di voi piace al cioccolato
quanti mentono
fin da piccolo ho mi è sempre piaciuto
mettere le mani in pasta o meglio del
cioccolato
ho cominciato la mia esperienza in
cominciando con una scuola professionale
a milano una scuola di pasticceria
e fin da piccolo appunto ho avuto questa
passione e in questa scuola di
pasticceria mi hanno mandato a fare uno
stage in un'importante pasticcere di
milano e in questa pasticceria ho avuto
la fortuna di la mattina andare a scuola
il pomeriggio di andare ad aiutare il
laboratorio e mentre aiutava in
laboratorio
quando finivano i miei colleghi io mi
fermavo la sera e
facevo cose
cominciavo a capire come funzionano le
materie prime de corato
perché è perché volevo crearmi uno
spazio di crescita personale
quindi ho investito su di me su questo
spazio di crescita e questo spazio di
crescita ma portato fino a vent'anni
quando poi la passione continua a
crescere l'amore per questo lavoro
continua a crescere
e
ho voluto
conoscere le basi dell'imprenditoria
perché ovviamente la passione ai l'amore
per questo lavoro ma non hai le basi
imprenditoriali ha 20 anni
e quindi mi sono
messo in società con un signore che
aveva già una pasticceria proprio per
capire come funzionasse l'imprenditoria
è andata molto bene abbiamo abbiamo
fatto dei numeri pazzeschi per essere
una piccola pasticceria di paese da 25
panettoni del primo anno che faceva lui
decorati il primo anno ne abbiamo fatti
130 quindi dei numeri enormi per una
piccola pasticceria
ma purtroppo l'esperienza fallisce è
un'esperienza che è fallita non a
livello imprenditoriale perché i numeri
andavano bene ma è fallita l'esperienza
relazionale
quindi mi sono trovato poi a 25 anni un
po ferito nella fiducia un po
ferito in nel mio campo professionale
allora ho deciso di tornare indietro
indietro ma con una visione diversa
indietro con
ritrovando il mio spazio di crescita
e sono tornato nella mia pasticcere di
milano
parlando con il mio ex datore di lavoro
ecco io rientro rientro come
responsabile di laboratorio ma
ho bisogno di avere date uno spazio di
crescita personale perché ne sento il
bisogno
lui mantiene la parola e ho avuto la
possibilità di gestire un laboratorio
con un team
e mai scritto al primo concorso di
cioccolateria un campionato italiano di
cioccolateria under 26
ero vinco lo vinco mi si apre un altro
mondo il mondo dei concorsi
ma questo mondo dei concorsi non mi apre
solo questa strada mi apre veramente
un'altra visione anche per il mio team
in laboratorio
uno spazio di condivisione quello che
prendevo mentre facevo i concorsi mentre
mi allenavo mentre facevo corsi di
formazione lo prendevo e lo portavo i
miei collaboratori e quindi questo dallo
spazio di crescita personale mi sono
spostato in questo spazio di
condivisione con il mio team proprio per
cercare di
relazionarmi con loro aprire gli spazi
aprirgli le idee aprire anche loro
questi interscambi che c'erano sempre e
quindi crescevo io e crescevano loro e
questo poi ci ha portato nel 2011 a
partecipare alla coppa del mondo di
pasticceria a lione dove abbiamo
raggiunto il secondo posto un traguardo
eccezionale
e quindi anche qui
continuavo a portare sempre questa
esperienza quindi organizzazione diversa
pulizia in laboratorio e gestione del
personale in maniera completamente
diversa da come è abituato un pasticcere
tradizionale e nel 2013 deciso di
partecipare al workshop con l'apt
masters di parigi
il workshop la massa di parigi ha il
campionato del mondo più prestigioso
importante di cioccolateria
in cosa consiste un campionato del mondo
di cioccolateria non è chi mangia più
cioccolato questo so che avete pensato
ma non è così
e a ottobre 2013
diventò campione del mondo di
cioccolateria e in cosa consiste però un
campionato del mondo di cioccolateria
intanto partecipano 24 nazioni da tutto
il mondo dove queste 24 nazioni vengono
i candidati vengono selezionati da delle
preselezioni regionali e nazionali
e
consiste in affrontare diverse prove
per esempio il cioccolatino stampato
questo è un cioccolatino di cui lo
stampo è stato studiato
disegnato ed è stato giudicato lo stampo
più innovativo nel mondo del cioccolato
negli ultimi 80 anni questo perché da
una forma ne uscivano 5 in base a come
lo giri
delle ganache particolari per i
cioccolatini
a immersione la torta al cioccolato
il dessert al piatto
questo è un pezzo artistico di cui tutti
i partecipanti avevano la stessa base
che era il mappamondo e ognuna
interpretava la sua visione di
architettura del gusto su un pezzo
piccolo e infine
infine il pezzo artistico da due metri
questo è stato un questo è completamente
in cioccolato è stato giudicata l'opera
in cioccolato più bella nel mondo dei
concorsi
ma
alla fine quello che ho portato a casa è
uno spazio di contaminazione
finché lavoriamo tra di noi nel nostro
settore abbiamo appunto questi spazi di
condivisione no tra il nostro team
crescita professionale ma lo spazio di
contaminazione qua è diventato più
grande di quello che pensavo infatti da
qui mi faccio l'esempio la vetraia che
ma ha fatto la copertura del dessert al
piatto per presentarlo all azienda di
plexigas per il montaggio della torta è
stato un montaggio completamente
innovativo per montare un dolce e quindi
la presentazione
lo spazio di contaminazione con le
persone alle persone del nostro settore
le persone di altri settori quindi
questa contaminazione che arriva anche
al di fuori da quello che è il nostro
settore professionale
perché poi alla fine le persone sono un
po come degli ingredienti no ognuno al
suo talento lo zucchero è buono il cacao
e buonissimo la vaniglia è buona ma
quando li mettiamo insieme
riusciamo veramente a creare
l'eccellenza del gusto no quindi la
metafora del cioccolato vi piace molto
per riuscire ad arrivare poi a un po
descrivere la mia ricetta segreta nou
dove in questa ricetta ci sono dei
valori dei valori che portano le persone
poi ad adattarsi agli spazi perché
quando apprendi qualcosa quando ti
contamini è un bagaglio culturale che lo
porti avanti in qualsiasi spazio vai
la determinazione a determinazione uno
di quei valori che ti permette di
arrivare all'obiettivo
ti permette di
rialzarti quando cadi
metafora pasticceria se sbagli una
ricetta la prima volta la seconda
cercherò di non sbagliarla di non fare
lo stesso errore
l'umiltà che è un po quello che ti
consente di continuare a confrontarti
con gli altri di rimanere coi piedi per
terra di veramente riuscire a continuare
a confrontarti dare lo spazio agli altri
di crescita e continuare a crescere ma
rimanendo sempre te stesso
e la professionalità che è quella parte
dove la contaminazione di questo spazio
diventa importante perché quando
acquisisci professionalità e riesce a
trasmetterla agli altri ma riesce anche
a prenderla dagli altri questo è un
bagaglio che ti rimane è una cosa tu a
ad oggi sono un imprenditore
che ancora la voglia di mettere le mani
in pasta come quel ragazzo di 14 anni è
continuo tutti i giorni ancora oggi con
il mio team
facciamo due briefing al giorno
riusciamo a relazionarci per
coltivare le idee di tutti
quando il discorso di avere uno spazio
di lavoro che sia corretto non lavorare
15 18 ore al giorno e pensare a quello
come è un massacro deve essere invece un
discorso dove fare le proprie ore in un
contesto ma riuscire veramente poi a
esprimere se stessi durante il lavoro e
questo è un una cosa cui ciò che ci
teniamo tantissimo
immaginate di essere a un tavolo con dei
cioccolatini sul tavolo del cioccolato
e
come
abbiamo già questi tre spazi su un
tavolo di cioccolatini
lo spazio di crescita di assaggio
passaggi tu hai un'idea io ho un'idea ma
è un interscambio io sento delle cose
che magari tu non senti è un confronto
uno spazio di condivisione
il cioccolato è condivisione
quando abbiamo del cioccolato e siamo
insieme seduti a un tavolo più
condivisione di quella penso che non
esista e infine uno spazio di
contaminazione il cacao cresce in
sudamerica
cresce in africa in tutta la fascia
equatoriale
questa è contaminazione contaminazione
perché arriva sul nostro tavolo
e da oggi
quanti di voi ameranno ancora di più il
cioccolato
grazie
[Applauso]